we will begin with this dr. David
Shulkin is out as Veterans Affairs
secretary and he is not going quietly he
writes in the New York Times this
morning the environment in Washington
has turned so toxic chaotic
disrespectful and subversive that it
became impossible for me to accomplish
the important work that our veterans
need and deserve president Trump fired
Shulkin yesterday and surprised many
people by choosing his White House
physician to replace him Rear Admiral
Ronnie Jackson has served the last three
presidents
he gave mr. Trump a glowing assessment
after a complete physical in January
David Shulkin joins a growing list of
more than two dozen officials to leave
the Trump administration major Garrett
is at the White House with the latest
cabinet shake-up major good morning good
morning Shogun's ouster is not a
surprise we reported on this program
nearly two weeks ago his job was in
serious jeopardy in February the VA
Inspector General determined that Shokan
used tax dollars to pay for a lavish
trip to Europe for his wife Shulkin
offered to repay the government but the
revelation caused him to lose backing
here at the White House in the aftermath
of all this Shulkin has said he is the
victim of quote politically based
attacks from people who wanted me out of
the way every day that was Veterans
Affairs Secretary David Shulkin on
Monday by last night he had been fired
are you his favorite cabinet secretary I
wouldn't say that on the campaign trail
mr. Trump repeatedly slammed the agency
under Shulkin the only Obama
administration holdover in the
president's cabinet the VA health care
program is a total disaster the
president later joked about firing
Shulkin from his administration will
never have to use those words will never
have to use those words in our David in
a scathing New York Times op-ed Shulkin
argued he was being pushed out by quote
people who want to put VA healthcare in
the hands of the private sector they saw
me as an obstacle to privatization who
had to be removed it's something
President Trump seemed to call for on
the campaign trail veterans should be
guaranteed the right to choose their
doctor in clinics
whether at a VA facility or at a private
medical center Shokan is a former
physician who ran hospitals and was
confirmed unanimously by the Senate the
president's choice to replace him he has
incredible genes his personal physician
Ronnie Jackson who administered the
president's first physical and lavished
praise on a president not known for his
fitness or healthy eating habits I think
he remained fit for duty for the
remainder of this term Jackson's
confirmation is by no means certain
Democrats have questioned his seeming
lack of experience heading of vast
bureaucracy the second largest federal
government agency that serves and treats
nearly nine million veterans as patients
Republicans also responded cautiously
praising shokhin and waiting to see what
Jackson would tell them in the
confirmation process in the end Shokan
said at the end of that op-ed piece
Norah it shouldn't be this hard
to serve your country a lot of people
thinking that major thank you so much